- Maligayang pagdating sa Pag-unawa sa
Quantum Information at Computation.
Ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous, at ako ang teknikal na direktor
ng IBM Quantum Education.
Ang layunin ng seryeng ito ay bigyan ka ng
matibay na pag-unawa sa quantum information at computation, at nangangahulugan ito ng pagpasok
sa mga teknikal na detalye
ng quantum information at ng pagkita kung paano talaga
gumagana ang quantum computing, kung ano ang kaya nito at kung ano ang hindi nito kaya.
Kung hindi mo pa napanood
ang overview video para sa seryeng ito, hinihikayat kita na tingnan iyon.
Sa video na iyon, makikita mo ang impormasyon tungkol sa kung anong uri ng background
na paghahanda ang inirerekomenda para sa seryeng ito, pati na rin ang isang balangkas ng
mga paksa na tatalakayin.
Gayundin, tiyaking tingnan
ang Qiskit textbook, na sumasaklaw sa parehong
materyal tulad ng video series na ito sa nakasulat na anyo,
at naglalaman din ito ng
mga interactive na bahagi at mga interface sa hardware at software na dinisenyo para matulungan kang mas maunawaan
ang quantum information at computation. Makikita mo ang mga link sa overview video at sa Qiskit textbook
sa description.
Ito ang aralin isa ng
unit isa ng serye.
Sinasaklaw ng unit isa ang mga pangunahing kaalaman
ng quantum information, at sa unang aralin ng unit na ito, magtutuon tayo sa kung paano
gumagana ang quantum information
para sa mga solong sistema, ibig sabihin ay mayroon
tayong isang pisikal na sistema o isang aparato ng ilang uri na
nag-iimbak ng quantum information
at tinitingnan natin kung paano
gumagana ang isang sistema o aparatong iyon nang mag-isa.
Sa aralin kasunod nito, tatalakayin natin kung paano
gumagana ang quantum information kapag mayroon tayong maraming sistema at papayagan iyon sa atin
na ilarawan ang mga kawili-wili
at mahalagang konsepto tulad ng mga quantum algorithm na gumagamit ng maraming qubit
at mga quantum protocol
na kinabibilangan ng maraming indibidwal na nagpoproseso ng quantum information at nagpapadala nito pabalik at
pasulong sa isa't isa.
Ngunit bago pumasok sa mga talakayan na iyon, makatuwirang magsimula sa
medyo simpleng setting ng isang solong sistema nang mag-isa,
bahagi ay dahil mabuti na magsimula nang simple, ngunit gayundin dahil tulad ng makikita natin, ang paglalarawan kung paano
gumagana ang quantum information
para sa mga solong sistema nang mag-isa ay humahantong nang napaka-natural at lohikal sa paglalarawan ng kung paano
para sa maraming sistema.
Narito ang isang maikling pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin.
Magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pagtalakay
ng klasikal na impormasyon.
Ngayon, ang layunin ng araling ito ay hindi upang ipaliwanag kung paano
gumagana ang klasikal na impormasyon, ito ay upang ipaliwanag kung paano
gumagana ang quantum information,
ngunit upang ipaliwanag kung paano
gumagana ang quantum information, napakatulong na magsimula
sa klasikal na impormasyon at gamitin ito bilang isang
pamilyar na sanggunian
kapag tinatalakay natin ang quantum information.
Sa antas ng matematika, ang quantum at klasikal na impormasyon ay may medyo katulad na mga paglalarawan na may ilang pangunahing pagkakaiba, syempre.
Sa katunayan, ang quantum information
ay hindi talaga hiwalay sa klasikal na impormasyon.
Ito ay isang extension ng
klasikal na impormasyon.
Ang katotohanan ng bagay
ay, hindi bababa sa sa aking pananaw, na hindi mo talaga
mauunawaan ang quantum information kung hindi mo naiintindihan
ang klasikal na impormasyon,
kaya ang pagsisimula sa klasikal
na impormasyon ay makatuwirang.
Inaasahan ko na ang
nilalamang ito ay magiging pamilyar sa ilang mga manonood, ngunit kahit na pamilyar ka rito, hindi ko inirerekomenda na laktawan mo ito.
Bukod sa pag-highlight ng mga aspeto ng klasikal na impormasyon na pinaka-kaugnay sa
pag-unawa ng quantum information, ipapakilala natin ang
Dirac notation sa bahaging ito,
na isang karaniwang paraan
na gagamitin natin upang ilarawan ang mga vector at
matrice sa buong serye.
Tulad ng lumalabas, ang Dirac notation ay hindi
partikular sa quantum information.
Maaari rin itong gamitin sa konteksto ng klasikal na impormasyon pati na rin sa maraming ibang setting kung saan lumabas ang mga vector at matrice.
Pagkatapos ay lilipat tayo sa quantum information, at partikular, tatalakayin
natin ang representasyon ng mga quantum state bilang mga vector,
isang simpleng uri ng sukat na tinatawag na standard basis measurement, at mga unitary na operasyon, na naglalarawan ng diskreto na pagbabago ng oras
sa mga quantum na sistema.
Muli, lahat sa setting
ng mga solong sistema.
Bago tayo magsimula sa aralin mismo, magiging kapaki-pakinabang na linawin na mayroon talagang dalawang paglalarawan
ng quantum information, ang pinasimpleng paglalarawan, na siyang
pag-uunahin natin sa araling ito
at sa buong unang unit na ito at ang pangkalahatang paglalarawan, na sinasaklaw sa isang huling unit, partikular sa
ikatlong unit ng serye.
Ang pinasimpleng paglalarawan,
tapat sa pangalan nito, ay mas simple at ito ang
karaniwang natututunan muna.
Sa pinasimpleng paglalarawan, tulad ng aking naiminungkahi na, ang mga quantum state ay kinakatawan ng mga vector at ang mga operasyon ay kinakatawan
ng mga unitary na matrice.
Ang paglalarawang ito ng quantum
information ay sapat para sa pag-unawa ng
karamihan sa mga quantum algorithm, halimbawa,
kaya hindi ito sobrang-simpleng, ito ang tunay na bagay.
Gayunpaman, tulad ng
matutuklasan natin habang tayo ay sumusulong, mayroon itong ilang mga limitasyon.
Halimbawa, kung nais nating
i-modelo ang mga epekto ng ingay sa mga quantum na sistema, ang paglalarawang ito ay nagiging kulang.
Ang pangkalahatang paglalarawan, sa
kabilang banda, ay mas pangkalahatan at sa huli, ito ay mas
makapangyarihan sa matematikong diwa.
Sa paglalarawang ito, ang mga quantum state ay kinakatawan ng isang espesyal na klase ng mga matrice
na tinatawag na density matrices,
at mas pangkalahatang klase ng
mga sukat at operasyon ay maaaring ilarawan kabilang ang
ingay, halimbawa.
Ito ay ganap na naaayon sa
pinasimpleng paglalarawan at sa katunayan, maaari mong essentially tingnan
ang pinasimpleng paglalarawan
bilang isang espesyal na kaso ng
pangkalahatang paglalarawan, at kasama rin nito ang klasikal na impormasyon bilang isang espesyal na kaso.
Napakaganda rin nito
kung paano gumagana ang lahat, kaya mahigpit kong hinihikayat kang matuto tungkol sa pangkalahatang paglalarawang ito
kapag handa ka na, ngunit ang pinasimpleng paglalarawan ay ang mas natural na lugar upang magsimula, at iyon ang gagawin natin.
Magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pag-usapan ang klasikal na impormasyon na may pagtuon sa mga aspeto
ng klasikal na impormasyon na pinaka-kaugnay
sa quantum information
at sa paraan na ito ay
inilarawan nang matematiko.
Isipin natin na mayroon tayong
pisikal na sistema o isang aparato ng ilang uri na nag-iimbak ng impormasyon.
Bibigyan natin ng pangalan ang sistemang ito na X, ngunit walang
mahalaga sa pangalang ito.
Maaari tayong gumamit ng anumang ibang
pangalan kung mas gusto natin, ngunit para pumili lang ng pangalan,
tatawagan natin ang sistema na X.
Gagawa tayo ng isang pagpapalagay tungkol sa X, na ang mayroon
isang may hangganan na hanay ng mga klasikal na estado na maaaring
naroon ang X sa anumang sandali.
Dito, kapag tinutukoy ko ang isang klasikal na estado, ibig ko sabihin ay isang konfigurasyong ng sistema na maaaring makilala at
mailarawan nang walang kalabuan
nang walang anumang kawalan ng katiyakan o pagkakamali.
Talagang ito ay isang bagay na maaari mong isipin nang intuitive. Sa antas ng matematika, tinutukoy lang natin ang
hanay ng mga klasikal na estado,
pinipili natin ito ayon sa gusto natin o sa paraang pinakamainam
na naglalarawan ng aparato na pinagtatrabahuhan natin.
Bigyan natin ng pangalan na sigma ang
hanay na ito ng mga klasikal na estado, at muli, hayaan akong bigyang-diin
na ipinapalagay natin na ang sigma ay isang may hangganan na hanay.
Ang hanay ng mga klasikal
na estado ng sistemang X na ito ay hindi walang hangganang malaki tulad ng
hanay ng lahat ng natural na numero.
Ito ay may hangganan, at iyon lang ay isang
pagpapalagay na ginagawa natin.
Halimbawa, maaaring ang X ay isang bit, kung saan, ang klasikal na hanay ng estado ay ang hanay na naglalaman ng dalawang
elemento: zero at isa.
Minsan tinutukoy natin ang
hanay na ito bilang binary alphabet.
Isa pang halimbawa ay ang X ay
isang karaniwang anim na mukha na dais, kung saan, ang mga klasikal na estado ay ang mga numerong isa hanggang anim.
Siyempre, pinag-uusapan natin
ang isang abstraction dito.
Ang aktwal na anim na mukha na dais ay maaaring
magkaroon ng maraming iba't ibang katangian tulad ng tiyak na
posisyon nito, ang oryentasyon nito,
ang temperatura nito, at iba pa. Ngunit tungkol sa impormasyon na pinaka-kadalasang kaugnay kapag pinag-uusapan natin ang isang anim na mukha na dais,
ang mga klasikal na estado ay
ang mga numerong isa hanggang anim na ipinahiwatig ng bilang ng mga tuldok sa kung aling gilid ng dais ang nakaharap pataas.
Kung ang X ay isang switch sa isang
karaniwang uri ng electric fan na maaari mong mayroon sa tahanan mo, kung gayon marahil ang mga klasikal na estado
ay ang mga setting na mataas,
katamtaman, mababa at patayin.
Mga halimbawa lang iyon. Maaari nating isipin ang mga sistema na may iba't ibang klasikal
na hanay ng estado kaysa sa mga ito, ngunit umaasa ako, ipinapaabot nila ang ideya
na ang konsepto ng isang klasikal na estado ay isang bagay na dapat
maging pamilyar at maaaring maunawaan sa simple at intuitive na mga termino.
Sa matematikong salita, ang hanay ng mga klasikal na estado
ay isang may hangganan na hanay lamang, at siyempre, ang hanay na ito ay dapat
ding hindi walang laman.
Dapat may kahit isa
na klasikal na estado na maaaring naroon ang sistema at dapat may kahit
dalawang klasikal na estado
kung ang sistema ay magiging kapaki-pakinabang para sa pag-iimbak ng impormasyon.
Ngayon, sa ilang mga sitwasyon, maaari nating malaman na ang X ay
nasa ilang partikular na estado, ngunit sa maraming sitwasyon,
na lumilitaw sa setting
ng pagpoproseso ng impormasyon, maaaring may kawalan ng katiyakan tungkol sa klasikal na estado ng isang
sistema sa isang partikular na sandali
upang ang bawat posibleng klasikal na estado ay may ilang posibilidad na nauugnay dito.
Halimbawa, kung ang X ay isang bit, kung gayon marahil ito ay ang kaso na ang X ay nasa klasikal na estado zero
na may posibilidad na tatlong-kapat at ito ay nasa estado isa
na may posibilidad na isang-kapat.
Tatukuyin natin ito
bilang isang probabilistic na estado, at maaari nating ipahayag
ang probabilistic na estado na ito, tulad ng nakikita mo dito,
sa pamamagitan ng pagsasaad kung ano
ang mga posibilidad para sa iba't ibang klasikal na estado.
Isang mas maikling paraan upang ipahayag
ang probabilistic na estado na ito ay sa pamamagitan ng isang vector, partikular ang representasyon
na nakikita mo dito
ay isang column vector, at ang vector na ito ay nagpapahiwatig
kung ano ang mga posibilidad para sa dalawang posibleng klasikal na estado.
Upang maging mas tiyak, ang unang entry ay nagpapahiwatig
kung ano ang posibilidad para sa X na nasa estado zero, at ang pangalawang entry ay nagsasabi
sa atin kung ano ang posibilidad
para sa sistema na nasa estado isa. Ito ay ang natural na paraan lamang para ayusin ang binary alphabet,
o hindi bababa sa, ito ang paraan na
sinanay tayong gawin ito. Na may zero muna at isa pangalawa.
Sa harap, gagamitin natin
ang terminong probability vector upang ipahiwatig ang isang vector tulad nito.
Partikular, ito ay isang vector na ang mga entry ay lahat
ng hindi negatibong tunay na numero at kung saan ang kabuuan ng
mga entry ay katumbas ng isa,
kaya makatuwirang
isipin ang mga entry na ito bilang mga posibilidad.
Dito sa halimbawang ito, mayroon lamang dalawang entry dahil mayroon lamang dalawang
klasikal na estado ng sistema na pinag-uusapan natin,
ngunit sa pangkalahatan, maaaring
magkaroon ng anumang bilang ng mga entry na may pag-unawa
na mayroon isang entry para sa bawat klasikal na estado
ng anumang sistema na pinag-uusapan natin.
Magpapatuloy tayo sa
pagtalakay ng klasikal na impormasyon, mga probability vector at
iba pa sa loob lamang ng isang sandali, ngunit una, magiging talagang kapaki-pakinabang ito
na ipakilala ang ilang notasyon
para sa paglalarawan ng mga vector na kilala bilang Dirac notation.
Sa katunayan, ito ay ang unang bahagi lamang ng Dirac notation.
Mayroon pang dalawang iba pang
aspeto ng Dirac notation na makikita natin sa kaunti
pa sa paglaon sa aralin.
Ang notasyong ito ay magiging
napakasentral sa paraan na inilalarawan natin ang quantum information, kaya mahalagang
maunawaan kung paano ito gumagana,
ngunit sa kabutihang palad, napakasimple nito at wala talaga itong
partikular na kaugnayan sa quantum information,
kaya maaari nating ipakilala ito ngayon
sa pamilyar na konteksto ng klasikal na impormasyon.
Tulad ng dati, ipinapalagay natin na mayroon tayong hanay na sigma ng
mga klasikal na estado ng ilang sistema, at ipagpalagay natin
na mayroon tayong isang pag-aayos
ng mga klasikal na estadong ito, tulad ng kung paano natin tinutukoy ang isang
pag-aayos ng binary alphabet
sa nakaraang halimbawa. Isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi nito
ay ang mga elemento ng sigma ay inilagay sa pagsusulatan
sa integer
mula isa hanggang kung gaano karaming
elemento ang nakapaloob sa sigma, na siyang kahulugan ng notasyong ito dito na may dalawang bar sa paligid ng sigma.
Iyan ang bilang ng
mga elemento sa hanay na sigma.
Kaya may unang estado,
pangalawang estado, at iba pa.
Ang tiyak na pag-aayos o
pagsusulatan na pinili natin ay hindi talaga mahalaga.
Ang talagang mahalaga ay
ang mayroon tayong pag-aayos at sisiguruhin nating sundin ito.
Para sa maraming klasikal na hanay ng estado
na mahaharap natin, magkakaroon ng isang karaniwang pag-aayos tulad ng mayroon tayo sa
binary alphabet,
at kung wala itong karaniwang pag-aayos, maaari tayong pumili ng isa.
Ngunit anuman ito, ang pag-unawa ay na sisiguruhin nating sundin ito.
Ngayon, narito ang notasyon
na ipinapakilala.
Para sa anumang pagpili ng isang klasikal
na estado a mula sa ating hanay na sigma, isinusulat natin ito dito, na binabasa bilang ket a
upang mangahulugang ang column vector
na may isa sa entry na katumbas ng a at zero para sa lahat ng iba pang entry.
Halimbawa, kung bumalik tayo
sa binary alphabet, na, tulad ng maaari mong nahulaan, ay isang napakahalagang halimbawa
na babalik tayo nang paulit-ulit. Kung gayon ang ket zero at ket one ay ang mga vector na tinukoy dito.
Ang ket zero ay ang vector
na may isa sa entry na katumbas ng klasikal na estado zero, na siyang unang entry,
at zero para sa lahat ng iba pang entry, at sa kasong ito, mayroon lamang
isang iba pang entry.
Katulad nito, ang ket one ay
ang vector na ito dito kung saan mayroon tayong isa sa
entry na katumbas ng isa,
na siyang pangalawang entry, at zero para sa lahat ng iba pang entry, na, muli, ay isang entry lamang.
Narito ang isa pang halimbawa. Sa halimbawang ito, mayroon tayong isang klasikal na hanay ng estado na sigma na katumbas ng apat na uri
sa isang karaniwang baraha: clubs, diamonds, hearts, at spades.
Sa kasong ito, walang talagang
karaniwang napagkasunduang pag-aayos ng mga uri na ito.
Para sa maraming laro ng baraha, walang pag-aayos. Apat lang na magkakaibang uri at iyon lang ang mahalaga, at may iba't ibang laro ng baraha na nag-aayos ng mga uri na ito
sa iba't ibang paraan, ngunit hindi talaga mahalaga.
Maaari tayong pumili lamang ng isang
pag-aayos tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Ito ay nagiging alpabetikong pag-aayos ayon sa mga pangalan ng apat na uri na ito na nakasulat sa Ingles,
Ipagpalagay na pumili tayo ng
partikular na pag-aayos na ito, pagkatapos ay tinutukoy natin ang apat na vector na ito: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts, at ket spades
tulad ng nakikita mo dito, at ang mga vector na ito ay katumbas
ng pangkalahatang paglalarawan na nakikita mo dito.
Dahil pinili natin
ang partikular na pag-aayos na ito para sa apat na uri na ito.
Maaari nating gawin ang parehong bagay para sa anumang klasikal na hanay ng estado
na pipiliin natin.
Tandaan na ang klasikal
na hanay ng estado ay palaging nangangahulugang may hangganan at hindi walang lamang hanay.
Ang mga vector ng ganitong anyo ay
tinatawag na standard basis vectors, at ito ay isang napaka-pangunahing katotohanan tungkol sa mga vector na ang bawat vector ay maaaring
ipahayag sa natatanging paraan
bilang isang linear na kombinasyon
ng mga standard basis vector.
Halimbawa, bumabalik sa halimbawa mula kamakailan lang, ang probability vector
na nakita natin ay maaaring ipahayag
tulad ng nakikita mo dito. Ito ay basically isang alternatibong paraan lamang ng pagpapahayag ng mga vector
na magiging napaka-maginhawa para sa ilang mga dahilan sa harap.
At sa notasyong iyon na nasa ating mga kamay na ngayon, bumalik tayo sa talakayan
ng klasikal na impormasyon at mga probabilistic na estado, lalo na.
At tingnan natin kung ano ang nangyayari
kapag sinusukat natin ang isang sistema habang ito ay nasa ilang probabilistic na estado.
Maaaring hindi tayo karaniwang
tumutukoy sa isang sukat o sa kilos ng pagsukat
ng isang bagay sa isang klasikal na setting, ngunit ang terminolohiya ay makatuwirang.
Sa esensya, kapag pinag-usapan natin
ang pagsukat ng sistema X sa kontekstong ito, ibig sabihin ay titingnan natin ito at makikilala natin kung anumang estado ito.
Siyempre, kapag tiningnan natin ang sistema, hindi tayo nakakakita ng probabilistic na estado, nakikita natin ang isang klasikal na estado,
at ang partikular
na klasikal na estado na nakikita natin ay isa na maaari
nating isipin na pinili nang random ayon sa mga posibilidad.
Ngayon, maaari kang magtutol sa
pilosopikal na batayan sa ideya na ang klasikal na estado na nakikita natin ay sa ilang paraan pinili nang random
sa sandaling sinusukat natin o tinitingnan natin ang sistema, ang sistema ay nasa ilang partikular na
klasikal na estado sa lahat ng oras
at natutunan lang natin
kung ano ang estado, ngunit para sa layunin ng pag-iisip tungkol sa matematikal
na balangkas na pinagtatrabahuhan natin,
maaaring isipin ito sa ganitong paraan at ang paggawa nito ay magpapahintulot sa atin na gumawa ng parallel sa
quantum information nang kaunti pa sa paglaon.
Ipagpalagay natin na ang
klasikal na estado na nakikita natin ay ang klasikal na estado a, na maaaring maging anumang estado sa ating hanay na sigma.
Binabago nito ang probabilistic
na estado ng X sa pangkalahatan, kahit man sa ating pananaw.
Ang mga posibilidad ay wala nang
kabuluhan dahil alam na natin kung ano
ang klasikal na estado ng X.
Ito ay a, at wala nang
anumang kawalan ng katiyakan tungkol dito.
Kaya sasabihin na natin ito
na ang posibilidad na ang sistema ay nasa estado a ay isa.
Alam natin ito dahil tiningnan na natin ito at nakita natin na ang klasikal na estado ay a, kaya ang bagong probabilistic na estado ng X ay isa
kung saan ang posibilidad ng
pagiging nasa klasikal na estado a ay katumbas ng isa.
At ang probabilistic na estado na iyon ay kinakatawan ng
probability vector na ket a.
Mayroon tayong isa sa entry na katumbas ng klasikal na estado a at zero sa lahat ng iba pang entry.
Halimbawa, kung isasaalang-alang natin muli
ang sitwasyon kung saan ang X ay isang bit at mayroon tayong parehong
probabilistic na estado tulad ng dati,
kung gayon kung susukat tayo ng X, maaari nating isipin na may
transition na nagaganap.
Na may posibilidad na tatlong-kapat, nakikita natin ang klasikal na estado zero, at sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat, lumilipat tayo sa ket zero
bilang ating probabilistic na estado,
at na may posibilidad na isang-kapat, lumilipat tayo sa ket one.
Maaari mong isipin ito bilang isang transition ng kaalaman kung mas gusto mo sa halip na isang aktwal
na pisikal na transition,
ngunit ang mahalaga para
sa layunin ng araling ito ay kilalanin kung paano gumagana ang matematika.
Medyo malinaw ito talaga, ngunit sa pamamagitan ng pagkilala sa katotohanang ito, ang katulad na paglalarawan
para sa quantum na setting
ay maaaring mukhang kaunting mas hindi misteryo.
Isang huling tala ay na sa ibang tao na hindi nakaroon na makita kung ano
ang klasikal na estado ng X nang sinukat natin ito,
ang probabilistic na estado
ay natural na hindi magbabago bilang resulta ng ating pagsukat nito.
Okay lang iyon. Ang iba't ibang indibidwal ay maaaring
magkaroon ng iba't ibang kaalaman ng isang partikular na sistema at naaangkop na pumili
ng iba't ibang probabilistic na estado
upang katawanin ang
kanilang kaalaman ng sistemang iyon.
Sa huling bahagi ng talakayan na ito ng klasikal na impormasyon, pag-uusapan natin ang mga klasikal na operasyon na maaaring isagawa sa isang sistema,
simula sa mga deterministic na operasyon.
Kapag nagsagawa tayo ng operasyon sa isang sistema, ang estado nito ay karaniwang nagbabago bilang resulta, at sa kontekstong ito, ang salitang deterministic ay nangangahulugang
na ang resulta ng pagsasagawa
ng operasyon ay ganap na nakasalalay sa anumang klasikal
na estado ng sistema
bago isagawa ang operasyon.
Sa ibang salita, walang
elemento ng pagkakataon kapag isang deterministic
na operasyon ang isinasagawa, kaya walang randomness
o kawalan ng katiyakan.
Sa matematikong termino, ang mga deterministic na operasyon
ay inilarawan ng mga function.
Bawat function f ng anyong
nakikita mo dito, na nangangahulugang parehong ang input at ang output ng function
ay katumbas ng mga elemento ng
ating klasikal na hanay ng estado na sigma ay naglalarawan ng isang deterministic na operasyon.
Ang klasikal na estado a ay
nagiging estado f ng a para sa bawat pagpili ng estado a.
Para sa bawat function f ng ganitong anyo, laging magkakaroon ng natatanging matrix M na tumutugon sa kondisyong ito
na nakikita mo dito,
at iyon ay ang sa pamamagitan ng pagpaparami
ng M sa vector na ket a ay nagbibigay sa atin ng vector na ket f ng a,
at iyon ay totoo para sa bawat
pagpili ng klasikal na estado a.
Hindi napakahirap na isulat
ang isang tahasang paglalarawan ng M habang anumang function f
ng ganitong anyo ang pinili natin.
Lagi itong magkakaroon nang eksakto
isang, isa sa bawat column na may bawat iba pang entry na katumbas ng zero.
At narito ang formula. Ang entry b, a ng M ay katumbas ng isa kung ang b ay katumbas ng f ng a
at kung hindi, ito ay katumbas ng zero, at sa pamamagitan nito, ibig sabihin natin
ito ay ang entry ng M na ang row ay katumbas ng b
at ang column ay katumbas ng a.
Makikita natin ang ilang halimbawa sa loob lamang ng isang sandali, at makikita natin kung bakit gumagana ang formula na ito.
Ngayon, maaaring hindi malinaw kung bakit nais nating kumuha ng isang function at ipahayag ito bilang isang matrix tulad nito,
ngunit makatuwirang gawin ito. Isa sa mga dahilan, at marahil, ito ang pangunahing dahilan, ay na kung mayroon tayong isang sistema
sa isang probabilistic na estado
at nagsasagawa tayo ng deterministic
na operasyon sa sistemang iyon, kung gayon ang resultang probabilistic
na estado ay maaaring makuha
sa pamamagitan ng matrix-vector multiplication, ibig sabihin, kung ang ating sistema ay
nasa isang probabilistic na estado
na kinakatawan ng
ilang probability vector v at nagsasagawa tayo ng deterministic
na operasyon na inilarawan ng M
sa sistemang iyon, kung gayon ang resultang probabilistic na estado ay ibibigay ng M times v.
Dito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang arrow na ito na may maliit na
bar dito ay isang karaniwang notasyon sa matematika para sa pagpapahiwatig kung paano ang isang
bagay ay nagiging
o nagiging isa pang bagay. Maaari kang gumamit ng karaniwang arrow, ngunit ito ay kombensyonal
at ito ay nakikilala at marahil ito ay kaunting mas tiyak kaysa sa isang arrow lamang, na maaaring mangahulugang maraming iba't ibang bagay.
Ngayon tingnan natin ang isang halimbawa o isang koleksyon ng mga halimbawa, talaga.
Tingnan natin kung ano ang nangyayari kapag kinuha natin ang ating klasikal na hanay ng estado sigma upang maging muli ang binary alphabet.
Hindi masyadong maraming iba't ibang function ng anyo na ating pinag-usapan kapag ito ang ating klasikal na hanay ng estado at upang maging mas tiyak, may apat lamang
na function ng ganitong anyo.
Dito, ang apat na function na iyon ay inilarawan ng tinatawag nilang mga talahanayan ng mga halaga.
Ang unang talahanayan ay naglalarawan
ng unang function, na pinangalanan naming f1.
Para sa bawat posibleng input sa kaliwa, inililista natin ang katumbas
na output sa kanan, kaya ang f1 ng zero ay katumbas ng zero,
at ang f1 ng isa ay, muli, katumbas ng zero, at iyon ay upang sabihin na ang f1 ay
ang constant zero function.
Palagi itong kumukuha ng halaga zero.
Ang pangalawang function f2
ay ang identity function.
Ang output ay palaging katumbas ng input tulad ng makikita mo mula sa pangalawang talahanayan.
Ang ikatlong function f3 ay
inilarawan ng ikatlong talahanayan.
Ang f3 ng zero ay katumbas ng isa, at ang f3 ng isa ay katumbas ng zero.
Ang function na ito ay mas
kilala bilang not function o logical negation.
Kung minsan tinatawag din natin ito na bit flip dahil ito ay nagba-flip ng zero
sa isa at isa sa zero.
Ang huling function f4 ay,
muli, isang constant function tulad ng una, ngunit ito ay ang constant one function
dahil palagi itong kumukuha ng halaga isa.
At iyon ang apat lamang na function mula sa binary alphabet patungkol sa sarili nito.
Narito ang apat na matrice na katumbas ng apat na function na ito na inilarawan ng
formula mula kanina,
na makikita mo dito, at kung nais mo, maaari kang mag-pause ng video at suriin ito.
Tandaan lamang na sa mga matrice, ang ayos ng mga indeks ay palaging mga row muna, column pangalawa.
Kaya ang entry b, a ay katumbas ng
row b at column a o ang row na katumbas
ng klasikal na estado b
at ang column na katumbas
ng klasikal na estado a.
Kaya halimbawa, kung titingnan natin
ang unang function, mayroon tayong f1 ng zero ay katumbas ng zero
at naaayon, ang
entry na zero, zero ng M1 ay katumbas ng isa.
Well, ang entry na isa, zero
na nasa dito ay katumbas ng zero, at maaari kang gumawa ng parehong bagay para sa kaso
kung saan ang input ay katumbas ng isa at katulad nito, para sa
tatlo pang function.
Maaari mo rin suriin na ito
ay ang formula mula kanina ay totoo at maaari kang pumunta isa-isa sa lahat ng iba't ibang
posibilidad upang ma-verify ito.
At sa katunayan, kung iniisip mo ang paraan ng
pagtatrabaho ng matrix multiplication, maaari mo talagang tignan ito.
Kapag pinarami mo ang isang matrix sa isang standard basis factor tulad nito, maaari mong isipin na
kinukuha mo ang input
at inilalagay ito sa
itaas ng isa sa mga matrice sa anumang column na katumbas
ng klasikal na estado
sa loob ng ket, at ang output na
makukuha mo ay ang column na iyon bilang isang probability vector.
Kaya halimbawa, ang M3 pinarami sa ket
zero ay nagbibigay sa iyo ng zero, isa
bilang isang probability vector, na siyang ket one.
Ang M3 pinarami sa ket
one ay nagbibigay sa iyo ng isa, zero, na siyang ket zero at iba pa.
Tatalakayin natin ang mga operasyon sa
mga probabilistic na estado nang kaunti pa sa sandali, ngunit una, ipakilala natin ang pangalawang bahagi ng Dirac notation.
Ito ay magiging kapaki-pakinabang
para sa pag-usapan ng mga operasyon at pag-iisip tungkol sa kanila bilang mga major C, at ito rin ay magiging isang karaniwang kasangkapan
na magpapatuloy tayong gamitin sa harap. Ang setup ay tulad ng dati.
Mayroon tayong anumang klasikal na hanay ng estado na sigma na pinagtatrabahuhan natin at ipinapalagay natin na mayroon tayong ilang paraan ng
pag-aayos ng mga klasikal na estado na iyon.
Pagkatapos ay isinusulat natin ito
na nakikita mo dito kung saan sa pagkakataong ito ang
angled bar ay nasa kaliwa sa halip na sa kanan upang mangahulugang ang row vector na may isa
sa entry na
katumbas ng a at zero para sa lahat ng iba pang entry na katumbas ng lahat ng
iba pang klasikal na estado.
Kaya ang pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng
bagay na ito at ket a ay na ito ay isang row vector at
ang ket a ay isang column vector,
ngunit kung hindi man, ang mga vector
ay tinukoy sa katulad na paraan.
Binabasa natin ito bilang bra a, hindi ako sigurado kung dapat itong maging nakakatawa, ngunit ang ideya ay ang mga pangalang bra at ket
ay dalawang kalahati ng salitang bracket, at magkakaroon pa tayo ng sasabihin
tungkol doon sa loob lamang ng isang sandali.
Ngunit una, tingnan natin
ang isang mabilis na halimbawa.
Para sa binary alphabet, mayroon tayong bra zero na
ito ay ang row vector dito na katulad ng ket a,
maliban na ito ay isang row vector
sa halip na isang column vector at ang bra one ay ang vector na ito dito.
Ngayon sa pangkalahatan, kung pinarami natin ang isang row
vector sa isang column vector, isinasaalang-alang lamang ang mga ito bilang mga matrice
na nagtataglay lamang ng
isang row o isang column lamang, kung gayon nakakakuha tayo ng isang isa sa isa na matrice, na maaari nating isipin
bilang isang scalar.
Dito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, dapat
mong isipin ang mga bituin na ito bilang kumakatawan ng mga arbitraryong numero.
Partikular, kung
pinarami natin ang row vector na bra a sa column vector na ket b,
kung gayon may dalawang bagay na maaaring mangyari.
Ang isa ay na ang a at b ay pantay, kaya sila ay parehong klasikal na estado, kung saan, ang mga isa ay magtutugma
at ang produkto ay katumbas ng isa o maaaring ang kaso
na ang a at b ay magkaiba,
at kaya ang mga isa ay hindi nagtutugma at ang produkto ay katumbas ng zero.
Isang simpleng paraan ng pagpapahayag
ng mga obserbasyon na ito ay tulad nito dito.
At para lang panatilihing maayos ang mga bagay, isinusulat natin ang produktong ito tulad nito na may isang bar lamang sa gitna at nangangahulugan ito ng eksakto parehong
bagay tulad ng dito.
At ngayon maaari mong makita kung paano ang
bra at ang ket ay nagsasama upang bumuo ng isang bracket, na
tinatawag din na inner product,
at iyon ay isang bagay
na napakahalaga na babalik tayo
sa aralin bilang tatlo.
Ang pagpaparami ng isang column
vector sa isang row vector, sa kabilang banda, ay nagbibigay sa atin ng isang matrix tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Kaya halimbawa, bumabalik muli
sa binary alphabet, kung pinarami natin ang ket zero sa bra zero,
ang makukuha natin ay ang matrix na ito dito, at maaari tayong dumaan
sa iba pang mga posibilidad upang makita kung ano ang mangyayari.
Ang ket zero times bra one ay nagbibigay
sa atin ng matrix na ito dito kung saan ang isa ay lumipat na
sa posisyong ito.
Ang ket one, bra zero ay ganito at narito ang ket one, bra one.
Ang nakikita nating nangyayari ay may isang isa lamang sa isang matrix na kung hindi man ay lahat ng zero, at ang posisyon ng isa na iyon
ay tinutukoy ng kung aling
mga klasikal na estado ang pinili natin sa bra at sa ket.
Mas tiyak, at
ito ay totoo sa pangkalahatan, para sa anumang pagpili ng isang klasikal na hanay ng estado, ang matrix na makukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng
pagpaparami ng ket a sa bra b
ay ang matrix na may isa sa entry na a, b at zero para sa lahat ng iba pang entry.
At ngayon na mayroon na tayong parehong una
at pangalawang bahagi ng Dirac notation, mayroon tayong isang napaka-maginhawang kasangkapan para sa pagkonekta ng mga operasyon sa mga matrice.
Kaya bumalik tayo nang maikli
sa mga deterministic na operasyon at alalahanin na kaunti
pa kanina sa aralin,
ito ay isinabi na para sa bawat function f ng
ganitong anyo dito, mayroon tayong deterministic na operasyon na nagbabago ng a sa f ng a
para sa bawat posibleng klasikal na estado a. At sinabi natin na para sa
anumang function tulad nito, laging may natatanging
matrix M na kumikilos tulad nito
sa mga standard basis na estado.
Gamit ang Dirac notation, maaari na nating ipahayag nang napakadaling ang matrix na ito tulad ng nakikita mo dito,
at maaari nating makita kung paano minsan
ay posibleng magtrabaho sa mga matrice nang ganap
sa loob ng balangkas ng Dirac notation
nang hindi kailanman tahasang nagko-convert
sa mga vector at matrice, ibig sabihin mga parihaba na puno ng mga numero.
Sa kasong ito, maaari nating suriin na ang
kinakailangang formula ay totoo sa pamamagitan ng pagpaparami ng M sa ket a.
Pinapalitan natin ang ating
pahayag para sa M tulad nito at maaari nating alisin ang parenthesis at pagsabayin ang bra
b sa ket a tulad nito.
At iyon ay dahil ang matrix
multiplication ay linear, sa kasong ito, sa unang argument at ito ay associated kaya maaari nating alisin ang mga parenthesis.
At ngayon, alalahanin na mayroon tayong naayos na a na pinag-uusapan natin habang nagbubuod tayo sa lahat ng
posibleng pagpili ng b,
ang bracket na ito dito ay
palaging katumbas ng zero kapag ang b ay hindi katumbas ng a, kaya walang
kontribusyon sa kabuuan,
at kapag ang b ay katumbas ng a, ang bracket ay katumbas ng isa at kaya naiwan tayo ng
isang termino lamang dito.
Iyon ang formula na gusto natin at kaya mayroon tayong napaka-maganda at simpleng paraan ng pagpapahayag ng isang function bilang isang matrix.
Bukod sa mga deterministic na operasyon, mayroon din tayong mga operasyon na
mismo ay nagpapakilala ng randomness o kawalan ng katiyakan tungkol sa
klasikal na estado ng isang sistema.
Ginagamit natin ang terminong probabilistic operation upang mangahulugang mga operasyon tulad nito, at upang maging tiyak, kapag sinabi nating probabilistic operation,
ibig sabihin ay mga operasyon na
maaaring magpakilala ng randomness, kaya ang mga deterministic na operasyon ay talagang isang espesyal na kaso
ng mga probabilistic na operasyon
na hindi lamang nagtataglay ng
anumang randomness.
Narito ang isang simpleng halimbawa kung saan
may ilang randomness na ipinakilala.
Ito ay isang operasyon sa isang solong bit. Ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho nito ay na kung ang klasikal na estado
ng bit ay zero,
kung gayon walang nangyayari. Ang bit ay nananatili bilang zero, ngunit kung ang klasikal
na estado ng bit ay isa, kung gayon ang operasyon ay nagba-flip ng bit sa zero
na may posibilidad na katumbas ng 1/2.
Walang espesyal na pangalan
para sa operasyong ito, kahit man sa aking kaalaman.
Halimbawa lang ito, ngunit maaari mong isipin ang pagsasagawa
ng operasyong ito sa isang bit.
Tulad ng mga deterministic na operasyon, ang mga probabilistic na operasyon ay maaaring
kinatawan ng mga matrice at ang kanilang mga aksyon sa mga probabilistic na estado
ay ibinibigay ng matrix-vector multiplication tulad ng dati.
Sa pagkakataong ito, hindi kinakailangang ang kaso na ang mga matrice ay may eksakto isang, isa sa bawat column at mga zero kung hindi man.
Ang mga probabilistic na operasyon ay
mas pangkalahatang kinakatawan ng mga stochastic na matrice.
Ito ay mga matrice na ang mga entry ay lahat ng
hindi negatibong tunay na numero at kung saan ang mga entry sa
bawat column ay nagbubuod sa isa.
Iyon ay katumbas ng pagsasabi
na ang mga stochastic na matrice ay mga matrice kung saan ang bawat column
ay bumubuo ng isang probability vector.
Makatuwirang ito kapag iniisip mo tungkol sa
aksyon ng isang matrix sa isang standard basis vector.
Isasaalang-alang mo ang anumang
klasikal na estado na nais mo at iisipin mo ang paglagay ng estado na iyon sa itaas ng matrix sa anumang column na katumbas
ng klasikal na estado na iyon,
at ang column na iyon ay nagsasabi sa iyo kung ano
ang probabilistic na estado na lumalabas bilang isang probability vector.
Ang probabilistic na operasyon
sa ating halimbawa, halimbawa, ay inilarawan ng matrix na ito dito.
Kung isasagawa natin ang operasyong ito
sa klasikal na estado zero, kung gayon ang probabilistic na estado na makukuha natin ay ibinibigay ng unang column,
na, muli, ay ang klasikal na estado zero o katumbas, ang probabilistic
na estado kung saan ang zero ay nangyayari na may posibilidad na isa.
Kung sa halip, isasagawa natin ang operasyong ito sa klasikal na estado isa, kung gayon epektibo naming na-randomize lang ang bit at naaayon, nakukuha natin
ang probability vector na ito dito
kung saan ang posibilidad para sa
bawat isa sa mga posibleng estado ay katumbas ng 1/2.
Sa pangkalahatan, kung isasagawa natin ang operasyong ito sa anumang probabilistic na estado, kung gayon ang epekto ay essentially
isang weighted average sa pagitan ng dalawang column
dahil iyon ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng matrix-vector
multiplication.
Ito ay linear, kaya ina-average lang natin ang dalawang
posibleng kinalabasan naayon.
Kapag iniisip natin ang mga probabilistic
na operasyon sa ganitong paraan, natural na isipin ang
kanila bilang potensyal na nagpapakilala o nag-iiniksyon ng randomness.
Maaari tayong basahin ang mga column isa-isa at maaari nating makita ang randomness
na ipinapakilala nila para sa bawat posibleng klasikal na estado.
Maaari mo ring isipin tungkol sa
mga probabilistic na operasyon sa kaunting iba pang paraan, na sila ay mga random na pagpili ng mga deterministic na operasyon.
Halimbawa, sa ating halimbawa, maaari nating isipin ang operasyong ito bilang katumbas ng
paghahagis ng isang tamang barya
at alinman sa pagsasagawa ng
constant zero function o ng identity function
bawat isa na may posibilidad na 1/2,
at maaari mong makita iyon na makikita
dito ng ekwasyong ito.
Iyon ay palaging posible para sa
anumang probabilistic na operasyon, at medyo intuitive ito.
Kung gumawa ka ng mga random na pagpili
bilang bahagi ng ilang proseso, maaari mong palaging isipin ang paggawa ng mga random na pagpili na iyon nang maaga
at pagkatapos ay i-hard code ang mga
pagpiling iyon sa ilang koleksyon ng mga deterministic na operasyon.
Minsan napakatulong na isipin tungkol sa mga probabilistic
na operasyon sa ganitong paraan, at makikita natin ang isang halimbawa
nito sa kalye sa ilang aralin.
Ang huling bagay na sasabihin
tungkol sa klasikal na impormasyon para sa araling ito ay ang tungkol sa pagsasama ng
mga probabilistic na operasyon, na nangangahulugang lamang ng pagsasagawa
ng isa pagkatapos ng isa.
Ipagpalagay natin na
mayroon tayong ilang sistema na pinangalanang X at ang M1 hanggang Mn ay mga stochastic na matrice na kumakatawan sa mga probabilistic
na operasyon sa X.
Isipin muna na mayroon
tayong isang probability vector v, na kumakatawan sa isang probabilistic
na estado ng X sa ilang sandali, at pagkatapos ay inilalapat muna
ang unang probabilistic na operasyon sa X, na kinakatawan ng matrix M1, at pagkatapos ay inilalapat natin ang pangalawang
probabilistic na operasyon,
na kinakatawan ng M2.
Kung gagawin natin iyon, kung gayon ang
probability vector na makukuha natin pagkatapos ilapat ang unang
operasyon ay M1 times v,
at pagkatapos kapag inilapat
natin ang pangalawang operasyon, ang resultang probability vector ay M2 pinarami sa anumang vector na nakuha natin
pagkatapos ilapat ang M1. Kaya ganito ang hitsura nito.
Ngayon, ang matrix multiplication
ay isang associative na operasyon, na nangangahulugang hindi mahalaga kung saan natin ilagay ang mga parenthesis na ito.
Kaya maaari nating ilagay ang mga parenthesis
tulad nito.
Iyon ay napakasimple, ngunit ito rin ay kawili-wili dahil inihahayag nito na maaari
nating isipin ang operasyon kung saan inilalapat muna natin ang M1
at pagkatapos ay inilalapat natin ang M2
bilang isang solong operasyon.
Sa ibang salita, ang
probabilistic na operasyon na makukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pagsasama ng una at
pangalawang probabilistic na operasyon ay kinakatawan ng
matrix product, M2 times M1,
at iyon ang parehong operasyon anuman ang probabilistic
na estado na sinimulan natin.
Hindi natin kailangang malaman ang anuman tungkol sa probability vector v upang isipin o ilarawan
ang nagsama na operasyong ito.
Pansinin na ang ayos
dito ay M2 sa kaliwa at M1 sa kanan, na dahil ang
matrix sa kanan, M1,
ay ang isa na pinarami
sa vector v, samantalang ang M2 ay pinarami
sa anumang vector na makukuha natin pagkatapos pinaramihin ng M1.
Kaya palagi tayong kailangang tandaan na ang ayos sa ilang
diwa ay binaliktad.
Ang operasyong isinagawa
muna ay ang nasa kanan at ang operasyong isinasagawa huling o sa kasong ito, pangalawa,
ay ang nasa kaliwa.
Kung hindi tayo titigil sa pangalawang operasyon at ilalapat natin ang lahat ng ito sa
ayos simula sa una at nagtatapos sa huli, na siyang Mn,
kung gayon ang komposisyon ng lahat
ng mga operasyong ito nang magkasama ay ibinibigay ng produktong
nakikita mo dito,
at makikita mo na ang pag-aayos
ay muli ay binaliktad para sa eksaktong parehong dahilan tulad ng dati.
Kaya sa madaling salita, ang mga komposisyon
ng mga probabilistic na operasyon ay kinakatawan ng mga produkto
ng mga stochastic na matrice na kumakatawan sa kanila.
Tandaan na ito ang
pag-aayos ng mga matrice sa produkto.
Palagi kang makakakuha ng isang stochastic na matrix sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng isang produkto ng
mga stochastic na matrice tulad nito, at minsan ipinapahayag natin ang katotohanang ito
sa pamamagitan ng pagsasabing ang mga stochastic
na matrice ay sarado sa ilalim ng multiplikasyon, at ang paraan na
maaari mong isipin ito ay na hindi ka makakalabas ng
hanay ng mga stochastic na matrice
sa pamamagitan ng pagpaparami sa kanila dahil ang hanay ay sarado.
Bumabalik sa
pag-aayos ng mga matrice sa produktong ito, mahalagang pansinin na ang
pag-aayos ay talagang mahalaga.
Ang matrix multiplication ay hindi commutative. Kung babaguhin mo ang pag-aayos ng
mga matrice sa produkto, maaari mong baguhin ang resulta,
at hindi na natin kailangang tumingin pa sa mga deterministic
na operasyon upang makita ito.
Narito ang isang simpleng halimbawa ng
dalawang stochastic na matrice, parehong kumakatawan sa
mga deterministic na operasyon kung saan mahalaga ang pag-aayos.
Kinakatawan ng M1 ang constant zero function. Ipagpalagay, inaakala natin na ang dalawang operasyong ito ay nasa mga bit, tulad ng halimbawa mula kanina.
Kinakatawan ng M2 ang not
na operasyon o isang bit flip.
Kung isasagawa mo ang M1 muna
at pagkatapos ay isasagawa mo ang M2, ang resulta ay ang matrix na ito dito, na kumakatawan sa
constant one function.
Kung itakda mo ang isang bit sa zero
at pagkatapos ay i-flip mo ito, ito ay kapareho ng
pagtatakda lamang ng bit na iyon sa isa.
Sa kabilang banda, kung isasagawa mo ang M2 muna
at pagkatapos ay isasagawa mo ang M1, ito ang resulta dito,
at makatuwirang ito dahil kung i-flip mo ang isang bit
at pagkatapos ay itakda mo ito sa zero, ito ay kapareho ng
pagtatakda lamang nito sa zero.
Hindi mahalaga na ni-flip mo ito. Malinaw, ang dalawang
matrice na ito ay hindi pareho, at kaya mayroon tayong napaka-
simpleng halimbawa na nagpapakita
na mahalaga ang ayos. Siyempre, hindi ito nakakagulat.
Alam nating lahat na ang ayos kung saan
isinasagawa ang mga operasyon ay mahalaga o hindi bababa sa, maaari itong maging mahalaga.
Halimbawa, kung mag-susiga ka ng
isang posporo at pagkatapos ay hihipan mo ito, ang resulta ay napaka-kaiba
mula sa paghihip sa posporo muna
at pagkatapos ay pag-susiga nito. Sa puntong ito, nagsalita na tayo nang marami
tungkol sa klasikal na impormasyon at ngayon ay panahon na
upang talakayin ang quantum information.
At ang mahahanap natin ay na
sa matematikong salita, ang quantum information ay gumagana
sa napaka-katulad na paraan sa klasikal na impormasyon
na may ilang pangunahing pagkakaiba.
Ang unang pangunahing pagkakaiba
ay nasa simula pa lamang, kung paano natin tinukoy ang isang estado, sa kasong ito, ang isang quantum state ng isang sistema,
at may isang diwa kung saan ang isang pagpili na ito kung
paano natin tinukoy ang isang quantum state ay malawak na tumutukoy kung paano
gumagana ang quantum information.
Tatukuyin din natin kung paano
gumagana ang mga sukat at operasyon, at sa susunod na aralin, tatalakayin natin kung paano
gumagana ang quantum information hindi lamang para sa mga solong sistema
kundi para sa maraming sistema,
ngunit ang mga bagay na ito ay talagang
sumusunod nang medyo natural kapag ang konsepto ng isang quantum state ng isang solong sistema sa
pagbubukod ay naitatag na.
Narito ang kahulugan. Isang quantum state ng isang sistema ay kinakatawan ng isang column vector na ang mga indeks ay inilagay
sa pagsusulatan sa mga
klasikal na estado ng sistemang iyon.
Kaya ipinapalagay natin dito na
ang sistema na pinag-uusapan natin ay may ilang hanay ng mga klasikal na estado, tulad ng noong pinag-usapan natin
ang klasikal na impormasyon
at mga probabilistic na estado. Ang mga entry sa isang quantum state
vector ay mga kumplikadong numero bilang kabaligtaran ng probabilistic na kaso
kung saan ang mga entry ay
hindi negatibong tunay na numero.
At sa pagkakataong ito, ang kabuuan ng absolute
na mga halaga na kvadrado ng mga entry ay dapat katumbas ng isa bilang kabaligtaran ng kabuuan na katumbas ng isa
tulad ng mayroon tayo sa probabilistic na kaso.
Ang mga kumplikadong numero na lumalabas
sa isang quantum state vector ay tinatawag minsan na amplitudes at gumaganap sila ng isang papel na
katulad ng mga posibilidad,
ngunit hindi sila mga posibilidad at wala silang parehong
interpretasyon.
Ngayon, hindi ko mabibigyan ka ng magandang dahilan kung bakit ang mga quantum state
ay dapat na tinukoy tulad nito maliban sa pagsasabing natuklasan ng mga pisiko
na ang kahulugang ito
ay may kaugnayan sa pisika at nagpapahintulot sa atin na ilarawan at i-modelo
ang mga quantum mechanical na sistema.
Sa ibang salita, pinipili natin ang kahulugang ito
dahil ito ay gumagana, hindi dahil mayroon
anumang partikular na dahilan kung bakit dapat
na tinukoy ang mga quantum state tulad nito.
Tungkol sa
matematika ng konsepto ng isang quantum state na ito, ang unang hakbang patungo sa pag-unawa nito at pagtrabaho dito ay
ang alalahanin ang kahulugang ito
para sa Euclidean norm ng isang vector, na maaari mong isipin nang geometriko bilang ang haba ng isang vector, tulad ng pag-iisip mo tungkol sa haba
ng isang dalawang-dimensional na tunay na vector kung ginuhit mo ito sa isang piraso
ng papel bilang isang arrow na nagsisimula mula sa pinagmulan sa karaniwang paraan.
Partikular, kung mayroon tayong isang
column vector v tulad nito, na ipinapalagay nating may
mga kumplikadong numero na entry, alpha isa hanggang alpha n,
kung gayon ang Euclidean norm ng v ay tinukoy tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Ito ang notasyon na
ginagamit natin para sa Euclidean norm na inilalagay ang mga doble na bar sa paligid ng anumang vector na pinag-uusapan natin.
Sa kasong ito, ito ay v, at ang paraan ng pagtukoy ng Euclidean norm ay na ito ang parisukat na ugat ng kabuuan
ng mga absolute na halaga na kvadrado
ng mga entry ng vector.
Kaya isa pang paraan upang tukuyin kung ano
ang isang quantum state vector ay na ang isang quantum state vector ay isang column vector na may
mga kumplikadong numero na entry
na ang Euclidean norm ay katumbas ng isa, na nangangahulugang ito ay isang unit vector tungkol sa Euclidean norm.
Iyon ay dahil ang kabuuan ng
absolute na halaga na kvadrado ay katumbas ng isa kung at kung ang Euclidean
norm ay katumbas ng isa.
Ang parisukat na ugat ay hindi nagbabago ng anuman kapag ang kabuuan ng mga absolute
na halaga na kvadrado ay katumbas ng isa.
Kaya iyon ang isang quantum state vector. Ito ay isang column vector na may mga indeks na katumbas ng mga
klasikal na estado ng isang sistema
na may mga kumplikadong numero na entry at Euclidean norm na katumbas ng isa.
Kung ano ang ibig sabihin nito o kung ano ang implikasyon nito o kung paano natin dapat i-interpret ang
konsepto na ito ay ibang bagay at sa ilang diwa,
ang pag-aaral ng quantum
information at computation ay isang pagsisiyasat ng kung ano
ang implikasyon ng kahulugang ito, hindi bababa sa, sa mga tuntunin ng
pagpoproseso ng impormasyon.
Ito ay ang simula lamang.
Bilang isang karagdagan, hayaan akong banggitin na mayroon
iba pang tinatawag na mga norm bukod sa Euclidean norm at ang notasyong ito dito na may mga doble na bar
sa paligid ng isang vector ay hindi palaging
nangangahulugang Euclidean norm.
Sa iba't ibang konteksto, ang notasyong ito ay maaaring tumukoy
sa ibang norm.
Halimbawa, ang kabuuan
ng mga absolute na halaga na walang mga squares o parisukat na ugat ay isang ibang norm,
madalas na tinatawag na one norm. Mayroon talagang maraming iba't ibang mga norm.
Kung minsan makikita mo
ang notasyong ito na ginagamit nang may isang subscript pagkatapos
ng pangalawang hanay ng mga bar na nagbibigay ng karagdagang impormasyon tungkol sa kung anong norm ang pinag-uusapan natin.
At kapag ginawa natin iyon, medyo tipikal na ang numerong dalawa bilang isang subscript
ay nangangahulugang Euclidean norm.
Ngunit sa seryeng ito, sa tuwing mayroon tayong isang
column vector tulad nito, ang doble na bar na notasyong ito nang mag-isa
ay nangangahulugang Euclidean norm.
Narito ang ilang mga halimbawa
ng mga quantum state vector at ang mga partikular na quantum state vector na ito ay mga qubit state vector,
na nangangahulugang ang mga
klasikal na estado ng ating sistema ay zero at isa.
Ang salitang qubit ay maikling para sa quantum bit, na talagang isang bit lamang
na maaaring nasa isang quantum state.
Ang unang dalawang halimbawa ay napakasimple. Ang mga standard basis vector
na ket zero at ket one ay mga quantum state vector.
Parehong mga column vector ang mga ito, at ang mga indeks ay katumbas
ng mga klasikal na estado ay zero at isa, at ang mga entry ng mga
vector na ito ay mga kumplikadong numero.
Para sa mga partikular na vector na ito, ang mga entry ay zero at isa, na mga tunay na numero, at sa katunayan, sila ay mga integer, ngunit sila rin ay mga kumplikadong numero
na nagtataglay ng
imaginary na bahagi na katumbas ng zero.
Ang bawat vector ay may isang entry na katumbas ng isa at isang entry na katumbas ng zero.
Kaya kapag kinubuwan natin ang absolute
na mga halaga ng mga entry, nakakakuha tayo ng isa sa parehong kaso.
Kaya ang mga kondisyon
na kinakailangan para sa mga vector na ito upang maging mga quantum state vector ay natutugunan.
Ang susunod na dalawang halimbawa ay napaka-karaniwang nakakatugon na mga qubit state na tinatawag na plus state at minus state.
Sila ay itinutukoy tulad ng
nakikita mo dito sa screen, alinman sa may ket plus
o ket minus tulad nito, at sila ay tinukoy tulad ng makikita mo dito.
Muli, ang mga entry ng mga
vector na ito ay mga kumplikadong numero. Sa pagkakataong ito, sila ay alinman positibong isa sa ibabaw ng parisukat na ugat ng dalawa o negatibong isa sa ibabaw ng parisukat na ugat ng dalawa,
at kapag kinubuwan natin ang
mga absolute na halaga na kvadrado, nakukuha natin ang 1/2 plus 1/2, na siyang isa.
Sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang paglalagay ng isang
plus sign o minus sign sa loob ng isang ket tulad nito
ay maaaring mukhang kaunting kakaiba dahil hindi ito mga klasikal
na estado ng ating sistema,
ngunit ang notasyong ito ay ginagamit pa rin, at babalik tayo dito sa loob lamang ng isang sandali.
Ngunit sa ngayon, sa madaling salita, maaari nating gamitin ang Dirac notation upang ilagay ang anumang pangalan na gusto natin para sa isang vector sa loob ng isang ket.
Ang vector ay hindi kailangang
maging isang standard basis vector kapag ginagamit natin ang Dirac notation.
Narito ang isang huling halimbawa ng qubit state
para sa sandali, sa anumang paraan.
Ito ay isang quantum state vector ng isang qubit na walang espesyal na pangalan, at hindi ito partikular na mahalaga.
Ang mga entry ng vector na ito ay isa plus dalawa times i
na hinati sa tatlo at negatibong 2/3.
Ito ay mga kumplikadong numero, at kung kinukumpute mo ang
mga absolute na halaga na kvadrado ng dalawang entry na ito, makukuha mo ang 5/9 para sa una
at 4/9 para sa pangalawa. Kaya ang kabuuan ng absolute
na halaga na kvadrado ay katumbas ng isa.
At narito ang isang huling halimbawa. Sa pagkakataong ito para sa isang sistema
na ang mga klasikal na estado ay ang apat na uri ng baraha.
Hindi ko alam kung bakit magkakaroon tayo ng sistema na ang mga klasikal na estado
ay ang apat na uri ng baraha na nasa isang quantum state, ngunit ito ay posible sa prinsipyo
at ito ay isang halimbawa lamang.
Ang mga entry na katumbas ng
iba't ibang uri ay 1/2 para sa clubs, negatibong
i na hinati sa dalawa para sa diamonds,
zero para sa hearts dahil hindi ito lumalabas sa kabuuan at isa sa ibabaw ng parisukat
na ugat ng dalawa para sa spades.
At narito kung paano ito magmumukhang
bilang isang column vector, ipagpalagay na nag-ayos tayo ng
mga klasikal na estado tulad ng dati,
na siyang ayos na
nakikita mo dito.
Ang pagkuha ng absolute na halaga
na kvadrado ng mga entry na ito ay nagbibigay ng isang-kapat para sa una, gayundin isang-kapat para sa susunod.
Ang absolute na halaga na kvadrado
ng zero ay katumbas ng zero, kaya ang entry na iyon ay hindi
nag-aambag sa kabuuan.
At sa wakas, para sa huli, nakukuha natin ang 1/2. Kaya ang kabuuan ay katumbas ng isa tulad ng kinakailangan para sa vector na ito
upang maging isang quantum state vector.
Ngayon kamakailan lang, ginamit natin ang notasyong
ket plus at ket minus upang tumukoy sa dalawang qubit state vector na hindi mga standard basis vector.
At nais ko bumalik
sa puntong ito nang maikli at ipaliwanag kung paano ginagamit ang Dirac notation para sa mga arbitrary na vector at hindi lamang para sa mga standard basis vector.
Tulad ng nabanggit ko na, maaari tayong gumamit ng anumang pangalan na
gusto natin sa loob ng isang bra o ket upang tumukoy sa isang vector.
Ang mga ket ay mga column vector
at ang mga bra ay mga row vector tulad ng dati.
Bilang isang halimbawa, ang Greek na titik
psi ay napaka-karaniwang ginagamit sa loob ng isang ket upang tumukoy sa ilang arbitrary na vector,
at dito, ginagamit natin ito upang
magbigay ng pangalan sa state vector mula kanina na wala
espesyal na pangalan.
Kapag ginawa natin ito, ang titik na psi ay hindi
kinakailangang may anumang kahulugan nang mag-isa.
Ito ay ang pangalan lamang ng isang vector, at ito ay nasa loob ng isang ket upang tulungan tayong linawin
na ito ay isang column vector.
Ito ay maaaring maging kaunting
nakakalito minsan, at mayroon pang potensyal para sa kalabuan kung ang titik na psi ay maaaring maiugnay
sa isang klasikal na estado ng
ilang sistema halimbawa, ngunit karaniwang hindi ito
nagdudulot ng anumang mga problema, at hindi mo kailangang gamitin
ang Dirac notation tulad nito
kung hindi mo gusto. Ang paggamit ng isang maliit na titik tulad ng
u, v, o w nang walang isang ket ay isang magandang paraan din upang
itukoy ang isang column vector
o mas partikular,
isang quantum state vector.
Ikaw na ang pipili kung anong notasyon
ang gagamitin mo upang ipahayag ang iyong sarili.
Kailangan mo lamang tiyakin
na una, ang kahulugan ng kung ano ang
nais mong ipahayag ay malinaw sa iba.
At pangalawa, na naiintindihan mo kung ano ang
nais na ipahayag ng iba kahit na ang kanilang mga kagustuhan para sa notasyon ay hindi katulad ng sa iyo.
Mayroon isang napakahalagang panuntunan para sa paggamit ng Dirac notation
para sa mga arbitrary na vector at iyon ay na kung mayroon kang isang column vector
na napagdesisyunan mong isulat
bilang ket psi, halimbawa, o maaaring may ibang
pangalan sa loob ng isang ket, kung gayon ang row vector na bra psi
ay naiintindihan na
ang conjugate transpose ng vector na ket psi.
At dito, ito ay nakasulat bilang isang ekwasyon kung saan ang dagger na ito dito ay tumutukoy sa conjugate transpose.
Kung ano talaga iyon ay
ang row vector na makukuha mo sa, una, pag-transpose ng vector, nangangahulugang i-flip mo
ang vector sa gilid nito at binabago mo ito mula sa column patungkol sa row
nang hindi aktwal na binabago ang mga entry. At pangalawa, ang pagkuha ng complex conjugate
ng bawat entry.
Maaari mong talagang isagawa
ang dalawang operasyong iyon, ang transpose at ang
entry-wise complex conjugate sa alinmang ayos o ang
dalawang operasyong iyon ay commute.
Kaya para sa vector sa halimbawang ito, dahil napagdesisyunan nating
tawagin ang vector na ito na ket psi, naiintindihan na ang bra psi
ay nangangahulugang vector na ito dito
kung saan na-transpose natin ang vector sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalit ng ket zero at ket
one sa bra zero at bra one, at kinuha natin ang complex
conjugate ng bawat entry,
kaya naman ang isa plus
dalawa times i na hinati sa tatlo ay nagiging isa minus dalawa
times i na hinati sa tatlo dito.
Narito kung paano magmumukhang ang mga vector na ito kapag nakasulat
nang tahas bilang isang column vector at isang row vector.
Pansinin, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, na
ang patakarang ito ay naaayon sa notasyon na ginagamit natin kapag mayroon tayong mga klasikal na estado
sa loob ng bra at ng ket.
Sa kasong iyon, ang mga entry ay lahat
zero maliban sa isa, isa, at kaya ang pagkuha ng complex
conjugate ay hindi nagtatrabaho sa kasong iyon.
Nakita na natin ngayon kung paano ang mga quantum state ay kinakatawan bilang mga vector, ngunit hindi malinaw sa
puntong ito kung ano ang kahulugan o implikasyon
sa mga tuntunin ng kung ano
ang maaari mong gawin sa sistema sa isang quantum state o kung paano ka makikipag-ugnayan dito.
Ang unang bagay na kailangang gawin natin upang mailapit ang mga isyung ito
ay ang talakayin ang mga sukat.
Sa intuitive na pagsasalita,
ang mga sukat ay nagbibigay ng mekanismo para sa pagkuha ng klasikal
na impormasyon mula sa mga quantum na sistema.
Kapag tiningnan natin ang isang sistema
kapag ito ay nasa isang quantum state, hindi tayo nakakakita ng isang quantum state tulad ng hindi tayo nakakakita
ng mga probabilistic na estado,
nakakakita tayo ng mga klasikal na estado, at ang konsepto ng isang sukat na ito ang nagbibigay ng interface.
Kung tayo, bilang mga tao, nais na malaman ang isang bagay tungkol sa isang quantum na sistema, kailangan nating sukatin ito, at sa paggawa nito, kukuha tayo ng klasikal na impormasyon
tungkol sa anumang quantum
na estado na nasa sistema na iyon.
Mayroon iba't ibang
mga konsepto ng mga sukat. Ang pagkakaiba ay isa
ng pangkalahatan talaga, at magsisimula tayo sa pinakasimple at pinaka-pangunahing isa,
na karaniwang tinatawag na isang
standard basis measurement.
Pangkakalahatain natin ito
sa mga susunod na aralin. Pag-uusapan natin ang tinatawag na
mga projective measurement sa aralin tatlo, at pagkatapos sa kalye sa
ikatlong unit ng serye,
pag-uusapan natin ang mga pangkalahatang sukat, na tinatawag din na positive
operator valued measures o POVMs para sa maikli.
Ngunit sa ngayon, lilimitahan natin ang ating atensyon sa mga standard basis measurement.
Kapag isang sukat ang
isinasagawa sa isang sistema, magkakaroon ng ilang hanay
ng mga posibleng kinalabasan ng sukat na iyon, na mga klasikal na kinalabasan,
at sa kaso ng isang
standard basis measurement, ang mga posibleng kinalabasan na iyon ay
eksakto ang mga klasikal na estado ng anumang sistema na sinusukat.
Ang bawat isa sa mga klasikal na estado na iyon ay magiging kinalabasan ng sukat na may ilang posibilidad, at ang posibilidad na iyon ay ang absolute na halaga na kvadrado
ng entry na katumbas ng
klasikal na estado na iyon ng anumang quantum state
vector na nasa sistema kaagad bago ito sinukat.
Alam natin na ang absolute na halaga na kvadrado ng anumang kumplikadong numero ay isang hindi negatibong tunay na numero, at alam natin mula sa kahulugan
ng mga quantum state vector
na ang kabuuan ng absolute
na halaga na kvadrado ng mga entry ng isang quantum state vector ay katumbas ng isa.
Kaya makatuwirang ito. Ang bawat klasikal na estado ay lalabas bilang kinalabasan ng
sukat na may ilang posibilidad at ang mga posibilidad ay nagbubuod sa isa.
Narito ang ilang mga halimbawa. Una, ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong isang
qubit sa plus state.
Kung susukat natin ang qubit na ito tungkol sa isang standard
basis measurement, nakukuha natin alinman sa zero o
isa bilang kinalabasan.
Ang posibilidad ng pagkuha ng zero ay ang absolute na halaga
na kvadrado ng isa sa ibabaw ng ugat ng dalawa, na siyang 1/2, at iyon ang parehong
posibilidad ng pagkuha ng isa.
Kaya kung susukat ka ng isang plus state, makakakuha ka ng isang uniform random na bit.
Kung ang sistema ay nasa isang minus
state sa halip na isang plus state, kung gayon ang pagsukat ay gumagana sa
eksakto parehong paraan.
Ang mga posibilidad ay, muli, 1/2 para sa bawat posibleng kinalabasan.
Ang pagkakaiba lamang dito ay ang plus sign ay naging minus sign, ngunit kapag kinuha natin ang absolute
na halaga, walang nagbabago.
Kung susukat natin ang qubit state na ito, ang posibilidad na makuha ang kinalabasan na zero ay ang absolute na halaga na kvadrado ng isa plus dalawa times i
na hinati sa tatlo, na siyang 5/9,
at ang posibilidad na makuha ang kinalabasan na isa ay ang absolute na halaga na kvadrado
ng negatibong 2/3, na siyang 4/9.
At sa wakas, ang pagsukat
ng standard basis state, ket zero ay nagbibigay ng kinalabasan
zero nang may katiyakan, at katulad nito, ang pagsukat ng estado ket one
ay nagbubunga ng kinalabasan na isa nang may katiyakan. Iyon ay dahil ang absolute
na halaga na kvadrado ng isa ay isa.
Katulad ng mayroon tayo sa
probabilistic na setting. Maaari nating iugnay ang mga quantum
state na ito, ket zero sa ket one, sa sistema na nasa
mga klasikal na estado na iyon,
at ang halimbawang ito ay naaayon
sa interpretasyong iyon.
Ngayon, tulad ng mayroon tayo sa
probabilistic na setting, kung susukat natin ang isang sistema kapag
ito ay nasa isang quantum state,
kung gayon ang estado ay magbabago, sa pangkalahatan, bilang resulta ng pagsasagawa
ng sukat na iyon.
Partikular, at muli, ito ay eksakto tulad ng mayroon tayo
sa probabilistic na setting.
Kung susukat natin ang isang sistema at ang kinalabasan ng sukat
ay ang klasikal na estado a, kung gayon ang bagong quantum state
ng sistema ay nagiging ket a.
Kaya para sa estado na ito dito
halimbawa, nakikita natin ang parehong uri
ng pag-uugali na mayroon tayo sa probabilistic na setting.
Kung susukat tayo kung gayon na may posibilidad na 5/9, makukuha natin ang kinalabasan na zero, kung saan, ang estado
ay lumilipat sa ket zero,
at na may posibilidad
na 4/9, ang kinalabasan ay isa, at ang estado ay lumilipat sa ket one.
Minsan ang penomenong ito ay tinutukoy bilang isang collapse
ng quantum state, at ito ang uri ng
bagay na nagpapanatiling gising
ng mga taong nag-aaral ng mga pundasyon
ng quantum mechanics sa gabi.
Ngunit mula sa isang purong
matematikal na pananaw, ito ay talagang napakasimple
at halos kapareho ng mayroon tayo sa probabilistic na kaso.
Ang pinagmumulan ng tensyon dito, sa ilang diwa, ay ang tungkol sa pangunahing
kalikasan ng mga quantum state at kung ano ang kinakatawan nila at kung paano sila naiiba
mula sa mga probabilistic na estado. Ngunit sa antas ng matematika, ito ay marahil kung ano ang maaari mong asahan.
Pansinin, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, na kung
susukat ka ng pangalawang beses, kung gayon makukuha mo ang eksakto
parehong resulta tulad ng para sa unang sukat.
Kaya may limitasyon kung gaano karaming klasikal na impormasyon ang maaaring makuha mula sa isang quantum state, at babalik tayo sa puntong ito sa lalong madaling panahon
sa isa pang aralin. Pinag-usapan natin ang mga quantum state pati na rin ang mga sukat, partikular na mga standard basis measurement,
na nagbibigay ng paraan upang
kumuha ng klasikal na impormasyon mula sa mga quantum state.
Ang natitirang paksa para sa
araling ito ay ang mga operasyon, partikular na mga unitary na operasyon, na naglalarawan kung paano ang mga quantum state ng mga sistema
ay maaaring mabago. Natural, dahil ang mga quantum
state vector ay iba mula sa mga probability vector, inaasahan mo na ang hanay ng mga pinahintulutang operasyon
sa mga quantum state ay iba kaysa sa mayroon tayo para sa
klasikal na impormasyon, at sa katunayan, ganoon nga.
Samantalang ang mga operasyon sa mga probabilistic na estado ay kinakatawan ng mga stochastic na matrice, ang mga operasyon sa mga quantum state vector
ay kinakatawan ng mga unitary na matrice.
Narito ang kahulugan ng mga unitary na matrice.
Isang square na matrix U na may mga kumplikadong
numero na entry ay unitary kung ito ay nakakatugon sa mga pagkakapantay-pantay
na nakikita mo dito.
Ang dagger ay kumakatawan sa
conjugate transpose, na nakita na natin para sa mga vector nang pinag-usapan natin ang Dirac
notation ilang sandali na ang nakalipas.
Dito ay isinasagawa natin ang
conjugate transpose sa isang matrix sa halip na isang vector, ngunit essentially kapareho ito.
I-transpose natin ang matrix, na nangangahulugang
pinalitan natin ang mga row at column, kaya ang entry na JK ay nagiging entry na KJ,
at gayundin kinukuha natin ang complex
conjugate ng bawat entry.
Gayundin, ang notasyong ito dito
ay nangangahulugang identity matrix.
Ang dalawang pagkakapantay-pantay na ito dito
ay talagang katumbas. Kung mayroon ka ng isa, kung gayon mayroon ka na rin
ng isa pa.
Parehong katumbas sila ng
pagsasabing ang U ay invertible, at ang inverse ay katumbas
ng conjugate transpose.
Iyon ay totoo lamang para sa mga square
na matrice, sa pamamagitan ng paraan. Kung mayroon kang isang matrix na hindi square, kung gayon ang isa sa dalawang
pagkakapantay-pantay na iyon ay maaaring totoo,
ngunit kung gayon ang isa ay hindi totoo.
Ngunit dito, pinag-uusapan natin
ang mga square na matrice.
Kaya ito ang karaniwang
kahulugan para sa mga unitary na matrice, at ito ay maganda dahil madaling suriin
kung ang isang matrix ay unitary.
Pinaramihin mo lamang ang matrix sa conjugate transpose nito sa alinmang gilid, at titingnan mo kung makukuha mo
ang identity matrix.
Mayroon isang katumbas na paraan upang makilala ang mga unitary na matrice, at iyon ay na ang isang
square na matrix ay unitary kung at kung hindi nito kailanman
binabago ang Euclidean norm
ng anumang vector kapag pinarami mo. Isang N sa N na matrix U ay unitary kung at kung ang
Euclidean norm ng U times v
ay katumbas ng Euclidean norm ng v para sa bawat n-dimensional na column vector v na may mga kumplikadong numero na entry.
At samakatuwid, kung ang v ay
isang quantum state vector, kung gayon ang U times v ay isang
quantum state vector din dahil ang mga quantum state vector
ay simpleng mga vector na may
Euclidean norm na katumbas ng isa.
Sa katunayan, maaari tayong magsabi ng kaunti pa, na ang mga unitary na matrice ay eksakto ang mga matrice na palaging binabago ang mga quantum state vector
sa mga quantum state vector. Iyon ay katulad na sitwasyon sa mayroon tayo para sa mga stochastic na matrice
at mga probability vector.
Ang mga stochastic na matrice
ay eksakto ang mga matrice na palaging binabago ang mga probability vector sa mga probability vector.
Kaya kapag napagdesisyunan na natin na ang mga operasyon ay dapat kinakatawan ng mga matrice, na kapareho ng pagsasabing ang mga pagbabago ay kumikilos nang linearly
sa mga vector na kumakatawan sa mga estado, ang mga pagpiling ito para sa mga hanay
ng mga pinahintulutang operasyon ay sumusunod nang natural, hindi bababa sa,
sa matematikal na diwa.
Ngayon tingnan natin ang ilang mga halimbawa ng qubit unitary na operasyon.
Makikita natin ang marami pang mga halimbawa
ng mga unitary na operasyon sa mga susunod na aralin, kabilang ang mga unitary na operasyon at mga sistema
na may higit sa dalawang klasikal na estado. Ngunit sa ngayon, magtutuon lang tayo
sa mga qubit unitary na operasyon.
Makikita nating muli ang mga
partikular na halimbawang ito nang paulit-ulit, kaya talagang kapaki-pakinabang na
makilala ang mga operasyong ito.
Ang unang koleksyon ng mga halimbawa ay ang tinatawag na mga Pauli na operasyon.
Ito ang mga operasyong katumbas ng mga Pauli na matrice, na ipinapakita dito.
Lahat sila ay unitary, at maaari mong suriin iyon para sa bawat isa ayon sa kahulugan mula kanina.
Ang mga partikular na matrice na ito
ay nagtataglay ng katangian na katumbas ng kanilang sariling conjugate transpose, na nangangahulugang sila ay lahat
mga Hermitian na matrice.
Kaya ang pagsuri na sila ay
lahat unitary, sa kasong ito, ay isang bagay ng pag-square ng bawat isa at pagtingin na ang resulta
ay ang identity matrix.
Ang mga pangalang nakikita mo para sa mga
matrice na ito ay medyo pamantayan, at makikita mo rin ang sigma
x, sigma y, at sigma z na tinatawag lamang na X, Y, at Z.
Ngunit dapat kang mag-ingat, na ang
mga malalaking titik na X, Y, at Z ay karaniwang ginagamit din para sa iba pang mga layunin, kahit sa konteksto ng
quantum information,
ngunit sila ay napaka-karaniwang
mga pangalan para sa mga matrice na ito.
Ang operasyong sigma x o X
ay tinatawag din na bit flip o not na operasyon, na nakita na natin
sa klasikal na konteksto.
At ang operasyong sigma z o Z
ay tinatawag din na phase flip.
At dito, maaari mong makita ang
aksyon ng mga operasyong ito sa mga standard basis factor, na medyo nagpapaliwanag
kung saan galing ang mga pangalang ito.
Tiyak, makatuwirang
tawaging sigma x bilang bit flip batay sa aksyong ito dito.
Ito ay simpleng nagba-flip ng bit mula
zero sa isa o isa sa zero.
Makatuwirang din
tawaging sigma z na phase flip batay sa aksyong ito dito.
Ngunit kung hindi iyon crystal clear
sa sandaling ito, okay lang iyon.
Mahaharap natin ang
operasyong ito nang paulit-ulit at ang kahalagahan
ng paglalagay ng minus sign sa harap ng ket one
na basis vector at hindi ket zero
at kung bakit iyon ay tinatawag na phase flip ay magiging mas malinaw sa kalye.
Ang susunod na halimbawa ay
ang Hadamard na operasyon, na kinakatawan ng
matrix na ito dito, na halos palaging pinangalanang H.
Ang pagsuri na ang H ay unitary ay muli ay isang
direktang kalkulasyon, na kung makalalayo ako, maaari mong makita dito.
Katulad ng mga Pauli na matrice, ang H ay sarili nitong conjugate transpose.
Kaya mayroon tayong pagkakapantay-pantay na ito dito, at kapag isinasagawa natin ang multiplikasyon, nakukuha natin ang identity matrix tulad ng kinakailangan.
Ang ikatlong halimbawa ay
talagang isang buong klase ng mga unitary na operasyon
na kilala bilang mga phase na operasyon.
Ito ay mga operasyon
na kinakatawan ng anumang matrix na kumukuha ng anyo na ito
na nakikita mo dito kung saan ang theta ay anumang tunay na numero.
Kaya ang entry na ito dito ay palaging
magiging ilang kumplikadong numero sa unit circle.
Ang mga matrix tulad nito ay palaging unitary, na iiwan ko sa iyo na i-verify.
Sa pagkakataong ito, ang conjugate transpose ay hindi katumbas ng orihinal na matrix maliban kung ang numerong ito dito ay nagtataglay
ng maging isa o minus isa,
kung saan, matapos ay makukuha natin alinman sa
identity matrix o sigma z, na
nakatagpo na natin.
Partikular, ang transposisyon
ay hindi gagawa ng anuman sa matrix na ito, ngunit ang pagkuha ng complex
conjugate ng bawat entry ay nagbabago ng entry na ito dito
sa e sa minus i theta.
Ang dalawang partikular na operasyong ito dito ay partikular na mahalagang
mga halimbawa ng mga phase na operasyon.
Para sa una, kinukuha natin
ang theta na maging pi na hinati sa dalawa, at nakukuha natin ang matrix na ito dito.
Ito ay karaniwang tinatawag na isang
S na operasyon o isang S gate kapag pinag-uusapan natin ang mga circuit, na hindi natin tatalakayin sa araling ito,
ngunit iyon ay isang mahalagang
paksa na malapit nang dumating.
Ang pangalawa ay ang operasyong ito. Ito ay isang T na operasyon o isang T gate.
At para dito, ang theta
ay katumbas ng pi na hinati sa apat. At kaya kapag kinukumpute natin ang exponential, nakukuha natin ang halagang ito dito, na siyang isa plus i sa ibabaw
ng parisukat na ugat ng dalawa.
Narito ang ilang mabilis na mga halimbawa upang makita ang ilan sa mga
operasyong ito sa aksyon.
Narito ang aksyon ng
Hadamard na operasyon sa ket zero at ket one.
Kung dadaan tayo sa
matrix-vector multiplication, makikita natin na ang nakukuha natin ay ang plus state at ang
minus state ayon sa pagkakasunod.
Kung isasagawa natin ang Hadamard na operasyon sa plus state at sa
minus state, sa kabilang banda, makubalik tayo sa ket zero at ket one.
Kaya kung linisin natin ng kaunti ang mga bagay, maaari nating makita ang aksyon nang mas malinaw.
Ang Hadamard na operasyon
ay nagbabago pabalik at pasulong sa pagitan ng zero state at ng plus state at sa pagitan ng one state
at ng minus state.
Tungkol sa dalawang ekwasyong ito dito, pansinin na nagbibigay ito sa atin ng simpleng paraan upang matukoy ang pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng isang plus state at isang minus state.
Tulad ng nakita natin kanina sa aralin, kung susukat tayo ng isang plus
state at isang minus state tungkol sa
standard basis measurement,
nakukuha natin ang isang uniform random na bit sa parehong kaso, na hindi tumutulong sa atin
upang matukoy ang pagkakaiba.
Ngunit kung isasagawa natin ang isang Hadamard
na operasyon at pagkatapos ay susukat tayo, makikita natin ang zero kung ang
orihinal na estado ay isang plus state
at isang isa kung ang orihinal
na estado ay isang minus state.
Kaya ang dalawang estado na ito ay talagang magkaiba, at maaari silang makilala
nang perpekto ng pamamaraang aking inilarawan,
na siyang ang pagsasagawa muna
ng isang Hadamard na operasyon at pagkatapos ay ang pagsukat.
Bumabalik sa halimbawa ng
isang qubit state na nakita natin kanina na hindi partikular na espesyal, maaari nating makita kung ano ang ginagawa ng Hadamard
na operasyon sa estado
sa pamamagitan ng pag-convert sa mga anyo
na nakikita mo dito at pagsasagawa ng multiplikasyon.
At narito ang resulta
na maaari nating i-convert pabalik sa Dirac notation kung nais natin,
at iyon ay isang paraan upang makumpute
ang mga ganitong uri ng aksyon.
Narito ang isa pang halimbawa na naglalarawan na hindi mo palaging
kailangang i-convert nang tahas sa isang matrix vector form.
Maaari mo ring isagawa ang mga
kalkulasyong ito nang direkta gamit ang Dirac notation.
Ang halimbawang ito ay tungkol sa T na operasyon, at narito ito dito
para lamang sa sanggunian.
Ang operasyong ito ay may aksyong ito dito sa mga standard basis state.
At kung nais nating makumpute
ang aksyon ng T na operasyon sa isang plus state, halimbawa, maaari tayong magsimula sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalawak ng
kahulugan ng plus state
at pagkatapos ay gamitin ang linearity
upang ipahayag ang resulta tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Maaari na tayong mag-plug in
ng mga pahayag na ito dito, gumawa lamang ng kaunting
pagpapasimple para sa pangalawang termino, at nakukuha natin ang resulta.
Kung para sa anumang dahilan nais nating mag-apply ng isang Hadamard
na operasyon sa resulta, maaari tayong gumawa ng katulad.
Una, pinapalitan natin ang pahayag para sa T na kumikilos sa plus state at ginagamit natin ang linearity tulad ng ginawa natin dati.
At ngayon, kung pinapalitan natin ang
mga pahayag na mayroon na tayo para sa Hadamard na operasyon
na kumikilos sa ket zero at ket one,
nakukuha natin ito. At ngayon, maaari nating palawakin ang
plus state at ang minus state upang makuha ang pahayag na ito dito,
na maaari nating pasimplehin sa pamamagitan ng pagdadagdag, at narito ang huling resulta.
Walang partikular na espesyal
sa halimbawang ito. Ito ay nilayong lamang
na ilarawan ang alternatibo ngunit katumbas na paraan ng
pag-compute ng mga aksyon
ng mga operasyong ito. Maaari kang gumamit ng kahit anong
paraan na mas maginhawa sa sitwasyong nasa kamay.
Isang huling punto tungkol sa
mga unitary na operasyon ay na ang mga komposisyon ng mga unitary
na operasyon ay kinakatawan ng matrix multiplication
tulad ng sa probabilistic na setting, ibig sabihin, maaari mong makumpute ang aksyon ng isang pagkakasunod ng mga unitary na operasyon
sa pamamagitan ng simpleng pagpaparami
ng mga matrice nang magkasama. At ang makukuha mo ay
isang solong unitary na matrix na kumakatawan sa pinagsama na aksyon
ng pagkakasunod ng mga operasyon.
Tulad ng mayroon tayo para sa mga stochastic na matrice, ang mga unitary na matrice ay
sarado sa ilalim ng multiplikasyon, kaya palagi kang makakakuha ng isang unitary na matrix
kapag pinagsama mo ang mga unitary na operasyon.
Kailangan mong tiyakin
na pinarami mo ang mga matrice sa tamang ayos.
Ngunit ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho nito ay tulad ng para sa
mga stochastic na operasyon kung saan ang matrix para sa
unang operasyong isinasagawa mo
ay palaging lalabas sa kanang bahagi
ng matrix product, at ang huli ay lalabas
sa kaliwang bahagi.
Kaya tulad ng dati, ang ayos ay binaliktad sa diwa na nag-cocompose ka mula kanan patungong kaliwa sa halip na kaliwa patungong kanan.
Narito ang isang kawili-wiling halimbawa na nagbubunga ng isang operasyon na kilala bilang ang square root of not na operasyon.
Ipagpalagay na una
tayong mag-apply ng isang Hadamard na operasyon kasunod ng isang S gate, kasunod ng isa pang Hadamard na operasyon.
Ang pinagsama na aksyon ng
tatlong operasyong ito ay inilarawan ng produktong ito.
Narito ang unang Hadamard na operasyon, narito ang S na operasyon, at narito ang pangalawang Hadamard na operasyon.
Kung isasagawa natin ang matrix multiplication, na hindi ipinapakita dito nang tahas, ngunit maaari mong gawin ito para sa
iyong sarili kung nais mo,
ang resulta ay ang matrix na ito dito. Ito ay isang unitary na matrix, at maaari nating suriin iyon nang direkta
o maaari tayong magtiwala sa katotohanang ang mga unitary na matrice ay
sarado sa ilalim ng multiplikasyon.
Kailangang maging unitary ito dahil ang tatlong matrice na ito ay unitary tulad ng nakita na natin.
Walang partikular
na quantum state vector sa isip natin dito.
Maaari nating isipin ang pagsasagawa
ng pagkakasunod ng mga operasyong ito sa anumang quantum state vector, at inilalarawan ng matrix na ito ang aksyon.
Ang dahilan kung bakit ang pinagsama na operasyong ito, ibig sabihin ang isa na inilarawan
ng matrix na ito dito ay tinatawag na square root of not na operasyon,
ay na sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa nito
nang dalawang beses, nakukuha natin ang isang not na operasyon, o sa ibang salita, isang
sigma x o isang X na operasyon.
Ang pagsasagawa ng operasyon
nang dalawang beses ay kinakatawan ng pag-square ng matrix o
pagpaparami nito sa sarili nito.
At kung gagawin mo ito, makikita mo na ang resulta
ay ang Pauli x matrix.
At iyon ay medyo kakaiba, at nagbibigay ito sa iyo ng isang pahiwatig na maaari kang gumawa ng ilang kawili-wiling mga bagay sa quantum information na hindi mo magagawa sa
klasikal na impormasyon.
Walang klasikal na operasyon, ibig sabihin ay isa na kinakatawan
ng isang stochastic na matrix na nagbibigay sa atin ng isang not na operasyon
kung isasagawa natin ito nang dalawang beses.
Kaya ito ay isang magandang halimbawa na nagpapahayag na ang mga quantum na operasyon
ay nagpapatakbo nang napaka-kaiba mula sa mga klasikal na operasyon.
At iyon na para sa aralin isa. Sa araling ito, tinatalakay natin kung paano gumagana ang quantum information para sa mga solong sistema nang mag-isa,
at sa susunod na aralin, pag-uusapan natin kung paano
gumagana ang quantum information para sa maraming sistema.
Salamat sa iyong panonood. Kung mayroon kang mga tanong, huwag mag-atubiling iwan ang mga ito sa
comments section sa ibaba.